classic toys are making a huge comeback
this holiday season
jc fernandez is taking us down memory
lane at rogue toys where you can get the
perfect retro gift for your child or
your inner child hey jc
hey guys december it is toy season i
feel like i'm in santa's workshop down
here at rogue toys
this is steve he is the owner so why are
retro toys bigger than ever you know
manufacturers have really latched on to
our nostalgia in our childhood and what
has happened
they've actually gone out and they've
recreated the toys to look and
feel vintage and that's really captured
both
adults and kids now kirsten and denise i
have a feeling that maybe did you have
these toys as a kid we have my little
pony cabbage patch kids
you know the my little pony is one of
those huge lines where both it's popular
with kids
and with adults cabbage patch kid
there's a nice vintage one for you
and barbies you can never go wrong you
know you got wonder woman coming out in
december
yeah wonder woman barbie that movie
comes out actually christmas day
and on this wall back here this was my
childhood back here
gi joe now looking at your gi figures
some
some of the stuff like this looks new
but that looks old what do we have
yeah so what you have here is you got
some modern gi joe this is made to look
like
the actual vintage original stuff again
they're capturing our childhoods and
they've recreated that now if you're a
product of the 80s like me it was gi joe
and it was he-man
let's go all right come on lance
so over here we've got our masters of
the universe and you can see
a lot of the stuff is made to look very
similar to both modern
and retro you've got a retro battle cat
and a modern battle cat
both of these similar in style both
original in the box on open
but you can see that they've made some
slight changes oh oh oh hold on
let's get a shot of this this has got to
be i'm sorry the best manger of 2020.
well i'll tell you what if you're really
into star wars what a great time to be a
collector because they've really
captured our childhoods
come on over here and i'll show you some
cool stuff with it
we have plenty of lots whoa we have lots
of star wars stuff here what's going on
over here steve you know so we got like
a vintage b-wing here made to look this
is an original b-wing from return of the
jedi and then right below it is a tie
fighter
that's modern made to look vintage but
still has
it right so it appeals that way you know
you've got boba fett slave one talk
about a home run that's going on right
now
one of the hottest toys on the market
right now boba fett stuff
now this is the land speeder the land
speeder and i know that ted
growing up this is what ted played with
ted asked santa for millennium falcon
and
maybe ted wasn't good that year because
this is what santa brought ted
ted this is taking you back to your
childhood back there well you know the
popularity of the mandalorian has really
kicked off
star wars fans in a whole other way you
have a toy like this it's one of the
hottest toys of the holidays
you've got the child grogu or known as
baby yoda
i mean these things all of this stuff
has been really hot the retro
toy to modern toy market is on fire
right now of course we got to point out
our third guest here this is uh e.t over
here hanging out with us steve thank you
so much road toys three locations in
town
we're gonna send it back to you guys i'm
gonna stay out here and play with some
toys